sports manciple her that's loud it was a
date night for beau Casper Smart and
Jennifer Lopez on Monday in LA the
couple hit the red carpet together for
the premiere of his new film of the
perfect match this girl is amazing when
she walks in the room
it's special and that is a beautiful
thing the 28 year old opened up to eat
about how special it was to share his
big night with his real-life leading
lady that's what we do man she's voice
manciple her that's loud what do you
think it's the key to making a
relationship work in Hollywood because
it's hard anywhere but in this town
especially hard work yeah yeah patient
yeah smart plays the role of Abram in
the romantic movie and his co-star
Terrence Jenkins appraised his comedic
chops
Jasper stole every scene he's in man
that guy is so funny he brings so much
energy parents told me you stole a lot
of scenes in this I did not absolutely
this was all parents and casseon and the
other cast I just I played a small pawn
in it I'm super grateful and super
excited for it it was an honor to be a
part of it the perfect match hits
theaters at March 11